nothing meant more than bein in the ring
with the Panthers my wrestling family in
the nineteen eighties we pulled in
audiences of millions
now we're pulling pints and I wouldn't
change a thing
really this is to be my final point eeny
what's he talking about we're going to
close the earth nails I can't be serious
yeah it's awful it's a poco well I quit
nothing so we do the greatest show of
our lives not gonna be easy trying to
turn the clock back nearly 30 bleeding
years
you look ridiculous they call me the
sexy c-3po twisty Ziggy barrows but
Ziggy shuffle but you short for yeah
territorial dancer
the Panthers you shall all be warriors
once more for I a so you are viral not
me May and clean as a whistle
nothing personal better than this
I fear the man now you've got the chance
he made this a fight that won't never be
forgotten yeah this is our moment
watch them learn
oh this rollin I don't think they're
stronger than cliff oh they're still
very little there
hey keep wafted keep often telly Oh got
me side back anywhere else a bonus it's
time to walk like the purpose that you
are like what do you want Leslie I love
you son Hey
you